Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thanks for joining
us at Candid Truth. We're going to talk
about the truth and we're going to get
candid with it. There is so much to talk
about you guys. Man, if you have eyes to
see, you will see the signs of the times
that all around us from aliens coming to
the externalization of the hierarchy to
uh Sunday laws being talked about to the
golden age that we are entering into to
AI surveillance. Everything is coming
together. 2025 is the beginning of the
end, I believe, with all my heart. And
it's exciting because Jesus is coming
soon. But it's also kind of crazy that
we're living in this time, that we're
seeing all this stuff happen. I actually
got some guests with me. If you guys
remember when we did the first Charlie
Kirk video, I had Jeremy Sorado on last
time. That was awesome. Thank you for
coming on, man. And I got my brother
Bradley in here from Bible Impulse. And
Bradley actually did a lot of research
on this stuff. So, I just thought, man,
from when me and Jeremy talked about
this from months ago to the stuff that
Brad's digging up, I thought this is the
perfect team to talk about this, man.
So, thank you guys for coming on.
Um,
>> absolutely. I
>> actually see somebody in the comments
saying that uh Charlie's wife already
talking about blue laws on podcast.
Crazy. how they are twisting the book,
pushing for Sunday rest, but ironically
it's pushing many to the true Sabbath.
Yeah, man. So, that's what we're looking
at. We're looking at there's a brand new
book came out like what, a week ago, if
that by Charlie Kirk. The last thing
Brad's got it right there. This is the
last thing that Charlie ever wrote and
it just happened to come out at this
time. I I don't think any of this is
coincidence. If you guys have been
following this channel, you already know
the line of thinking that I have that
many other people have that when there
are big events, my antenna go up and I
start looking at stuff and I start
seeing things that don't line up.
Whether it's 9/11, whether it's Sandy
Hook, whatever it is, there are details
that don't line up with the official
narrative that the news says. And so,
we've done three videos. If this is your
first time hearing anything from us
about Charlie Kirk, go back and check
out there's me and Jeremy went for two
hours looking at how Erica Kirk is is a
a trained Jesuit. She went to Jesuit
college. She's wearing a Maltese cross.
Um how Charlie's throwing up the Masonic
hand signs. He's sharing the stage with
Trump. He's on mainstream media
controlled propaganda. like you don't
get to be this level of politics to get
to be on mainstream control media um and
and share the stage with Trump unless
you're a part of the system. That's just
the way I I believe. And um I believe
all of this was planned for a reason.
So, check out the first video, the
second video that had uh predictive
programming from Snake Eyes and also the
Hulu show called Tempest where the very
day that Charlie got shot, the the very
same day Charlie got shot was the
premiere of this show where a
extreme Republican
guy was running for president, gets shot
in the neck, and his wife picks up the
torch. I mean, this is [clears throat]
you can't make this stuff up. All right?
And then the third video was showing all
the inconsistencies with the event. I
mean, the bullet hole not lining up,
blood not going into the shirt, no blood
on the way to the SUV, lots of things.
Check it out. Look for yourself. Make up
your own mind. Look at all the evidence.
But all that said,
we know prophetically that there is a
there's going to be a push for a one
world religion in these last days. It's
prophetic. And you know, Satan has to
figure out a way to get the conservative
right on board with everything, right?
And the Democrat and the Democrat left.
So, he's already got the left. They're
all about we don't, you know, uh they
don't want freedom of speech. They want
censorship, the hate speech and all this
stuff. Take it away. We don't want
freedom of speech. But the right was all
for it. Freedom of speech until this
event happened, right? Then it was if if
anybody says anything bad about Charlie,
tell their bosses. We want them to lose
their job. Right? So, there's been a
major shift. Everyone's being funneled
into this system of control and you
can't say what you want to say and and
all this stuff. And so, I believe that
Charlie was purposely created as a a
hero for the conservative right. You
know, he he said a lot of good things,
but so does the devil, right? The devil
speaks in a lot of truth with a little
bit of error. That's what happened in
the Garden of Eden, right? You can eat
of every tree, right? But not this one.
And so, yeah, he said a lot of good
stuff that we can agree with. And but we
live in such a twisted world. These
people operate out of order, out of
chaos. They've created the chaos. We
live in a chaotic world where there's 86
genders. Chop the genitals off your
kids. And now if somebody gets on stage
and says there's only two genders,
everyone gets up and cheers like you're
a hero, but you're really just speaking
normaly again. And so I don't really
think that, you know, that's what I'm
getting at like this person was created
to be this hero so that this very thing
could happen. And think about it.
Um when when a celebrity dies, suddenly
the sales go up, right?
Suddenly everyone's Michael Jackson's
biggest fan. All the records get skyhigh
because all of a sudden now this
person's looked at like, "Oh, I I want
to think about them, a memorial or
whatever." And so I don't think it's any
coincidence that this death happened
right before this book, his final words
came out. All right, I said too much.
You guys take it away, man. What you
What you got to say?
Um, I mean, uh, um, welcome everybody.
Um, as Mikey said, just to reiterate, we
are definitely, we're living in that
time. And, you know, some people are
scared. Some people are neutral. They're
not paying attention. They're going
about their lives like, well, oh, it'll
pass over. And then you have that other
group of people where, you know, they're
like, we're we're we're literally living
in that time. like and I'm excited, you
know, I'm excited for this because this
is something that I've been reading
about, studying. I've been reading the
the scriptures and now,
you know, we're living in that time. And
so, as Mikey said, today we we're going
to we're going to take a look at some of
the experts and and um things that was
written um supposedly written by Kirk
because we know we we we have people who
are saying it may have been uh tarnished
or somebody may have placed their own
words in the place of it's like you
don't know. But today we're going to
we're [clears throat] going to look at
some things that
um may contribute to,
you know, to show you that possibly,
yeah, he did have a hand in writing this
book. And I don't I don't personally
based on my uh my studies and my
understanding of what he believed in um
and how it was consistent. We we're
going to see that both the book and
things that came out of his mouth were
literally the same.
>> Jeremy, you got you got an opening
statement you want to say something
about?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Yeah. This is uh this isn't about
attacking a person,
but uh examining ideas and movements.
We know that the Bible warns us uh the
great deceptions come clothed in
religious revival and we're seeing a
major religious revival taking place
right now in the world. This is huge.
This is this is unprecedented.
uh this is the end times deception we
think is here or it's there or it's
atheism or whatever but it's it's false
Christianity and we need to really be
putting a magnet mine glass on this and
scrutinizing whatever it is that's
taking place because false Christs and
false prophets shall arise and shall
show great signs and wonders and they
will uh deceive many and so we need to
be very careful
>> um because uh we're facing the very end
of all things right now. So, we need to
be very sober as we look into these
things. And I'm excited to get into
this. Amen.
Good stuff, man.
So, what we got here? Charlie passing
the baton.
So, in order for the book to have been
tampered with, that would mean she'd
have to be involved in some way, right?
I mean, because she's promoting the
book.
I mean, that would that would have to
mean like there's a huge conspiracy like
she had her husband killed and she just
did it to take over. Maybe she was like
some Jesuit plant or whatever. I've
thought about all these different
things. There's many reasons why I don't
believe that's the case. Like I said, he
throws up the hand signs. He's sharing
the stage with Trump. He's got the
mainstream media propaganda, all that
stuff. But um
yeah, you would have to think that. I
guess if you think that the book's been
tampered with,
>> I the image the image right here is
self-explanatory. Um you know, he's not
u he's according to media, he's
deceased, right?
>> So it's we're we're
>> we're looking at this image and you're
asking yourself, okay, what's going on
now? What's what's the next step? He
passes the baton over to his wife and
now you have to pay close attention to
the things that she is saying too
>> because now she's in control. So she's
the
>> she's the how can I say the poster
child. She's like the poster child for
Turning Point um USA. So what comes out
of her mouth is very very important. So
yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Read the Bible again. Go to church next
Sunday and the Sunday after that and
break free from the temptations and
shackles of this world.
>> So what's what's going on here? You you
you're seeing her view.
>> You're seeing that what she believes in.
Dude, I I can see how this could be so
deceptive to people that don't really
understand Bible prophecy because I grew
up in your mainline Baptist church where
you watched uh Left Behind series and
you believe that there's going to be a
pre-tribulation rapture. you believe is
going to be a an antichrist that just
this one man, you know, probably
American president that just or maybe
comes out of Jerusalem or whatever, but
there's this one man antichrist and he
just hates Christianity and everything,
killing Christians in the street and
everything, but that's really not what
the Bible says.
When you really study prophecy, the
antichrist is going to be I don't
believe it's just one being either
except when Satan appears as Christ, but
it's going to be something that looks
it's like in place of Christ. Not not
anti, not against, but in place of and
it's going to be a false system of
worship. And like we just said, the
devil speaks a lot of truth with a
little bit of error. That's how
deception works. Dude, you I I have like
new age books that I look at as research
and it's like every page is scripture. I
mean, scripture after scripture after
scripture. And if you were just if you
had just come to the Christian faith and
you found that book, you'd be like,
"Wow, this is great. This is a great
book talking about Christ within the
kingdom within and all this stuff. And I
meditate on his words and all this
stuff." But it's it's deceptive. It's a
lot of good things in there. It sounds
like because it's words out of
scripture, but it's out of context. And
so, we know that there's going to be a
one world religion that's going to look
so close to the truth that it's going to
deceive millions of Christians and it's
going to look like a coexist,
acceptance, love, peace. It says when
when they say peace and safety, sudden
destruction will come upon them. And
it's going to look like tolerance. You
know, we keep hearing about this
tolerance and acceptance and all that
stuff. And yet, the only ones that are
are really not tolerated or accepted are
true Christians. The ones who truly live
by thus sayeth the Lord. You're the only
one that gets attacked because you
believe that your way is the only way.
That there's only one way.
>> That's right.
>> You want to go to the next slide?
>> Yes, please. So, this is this is a
forward um that was written by Eric
Kirk. It's in the beginning of the book,
and I want you to see the subtlety
and and it's it's very f it's I'm not
going to say it's funny. It's something
to take seriously because later on as we
proceed within the the presentation,
you'll notice that these words are once
again repeated by Charlie Kirk later
within the book. So, let's just read it.
Says, "In full transparency,
there were moments when responsibilities
pressed in and work could not wait. And
he speaking about Charlie [snorts]
switched his Sabbath day to a different
day of the week.
>> And then here it goes. But perfection
was never the aim.
>> His desire was obedience. And in obed in
that obedience, he was learning week by
week to quiet the clamor of the world
and to trust the God who holds it all.
to the to to the Christian
>> it who has discernments. There's so much
deception here. I I What do you guys see
here? Like it's it's there. What do you
guys see there?
>> Well, I I see that you can just change
God's law. You know, it's like, you
know, I know the Bible says um
thou shalt not steal, but I'm borrowing.
you know, I'm not really stealing. I
borrowed without asking or I don't know.
I mean, you can't just change any of
God's laws. He's the God that never
changes. He doesn't change. So, what
makes what makes us think that we can
compromise and say, "Well, you know, uh,
I like to keep God's fourth commandment
when I can, but sometimes things come up
and, you know, I just do a little
switcheroo. I'll just keep it on another
day.
It's it's I mean it's there he'd switch
his Sabbath day to a different day of
the week. But my my thing for me was
what stuck out for me cuz this was this
was the common theme throughout the
whole entire book.
>> The switching of the day. Oh, we lost
him. The switching of the day and so
forth.
>> But specifically in that portion, she
says it was never his aim to be perfect.
What?
>> That's interesting.
What? And if and if you continue, I
mean, this is this goes against what
scripture says.
>> And this is subtlety. Yeah.
>> Right. Matthew 5:48, "Be ye therefore
perfect, even as your father which is in
heaven is perfect."
>> Genesis 17:1, what what does that say?
If you can continue on,
>> I am the Almighty God. Walk before me
and be thou perfect.
And lastly, you got Psalms 37. Listen,
it says mark that mean seal.
>> Okay, mark seal the perfect man and
behold the upright for the end of that
man is peace.
>> So in order to be sealed, you have to be
perfect.
>> Now the question becomes this is this is
what a lot of Christians struggle with
because they hear perfect. We could
never be perfect,
>> right? No, it's it's what happens is our
understanding of perfect in the lines of
scripture has been distorted by the
worldly view.
>> So if we can go on to the next slide and
I'll show y'all this scripture here is
in Mark 4:28 and it's a parable and
Christ says for the earth bringeth forth
fruit of herself first the blade then
the ear after that the full coin in the
air. So for those who are sitting here
and saying I could never be perfect. No,
Christ is telling you here as a parable.
These are stages of the Christian life.
You have the people who are just coming
in. They're the they start off as the
blade and as they progress they become
the air and then finally they're the
full corner of the air. And what Christ
is telling you you can be perfect at
each of these stages. In other words,
perfection in the lens
perfection in the lens of scripture is
what? It's you living up to all the
light that God has given you at that
point. And if you're walking in all that
that that light as best as you can,
you're considered perfect in God's eyes.
This is why a lot of people um in the
end times when God calls people out of
Babylon
>> Yeah. and they come to join, some of
those people will be amongst the
144,000, believe it or not,
>> because they were living up to all the
light that they they had at that time.
>> Amen. Yeah. I see some good questions uh
in the chat. Somebody said, "Look, man,
he's not SDA. He can't get everything
right, but I don't think you got to be a
seventh day Adventist to keep the sa
Saturday 7th day Sabbath." You know,
it's like
>> it's the fourth commandment. It's clear.
Like it doesn't say remember a day. It
says remember the seventh day. I mean
it's all through the Bible. Um you don't
have to be an Adventist to be able to to
know what day is the seventh day.
I think I think it's important that we
detach ourselves from the person and
focus on the words that are being said
because emotions can drive us to defend
the person, not so much the the the the
things that are being said that those
things are are losing traction. They're
not being analyzed. So again, um Jeremy
said it earlier. We're not coming after
this brother's um you know, character.
We're not.
>> Yeah.
>> There are things that are being said. We
we are told throughout scripture, study
to show yourself approved.
>> You know, divide the you're supposed to
be dividing the scriptures line upon
line, precept upon precept. That
principle
should be applied through all life. Do
you just believe something that somebody
says as they say it or do you
investigate it? This is what you guys
do. This is what they do on this
platform. You don't take everything,
you know, you don't take everyone's word
once they say these things. You got to
go and investigate to see if it's true.
The Bible called these people Bereans.
>> Test the spirit,
>> you know. So that's it. Test the
spirits.
>> That's what we got.
>> So yeah. So here we got this is
um this was uh how can I say this?
So these were some comments that I seen
and this is why I I want to encourage
people to use your discernment
and you need to study every aspect
because there's an emotional attachment
>> and there's an emotional attachment to
Charlie Kirk as the individual
and um
>> that's right
>> yeah and people are not investigating.
So, as you clearly see here, um here's
one comment that someone said. Where did
they get this from? Charlie Clark
Charlie um never honor Sunday. He always
speaks of the Jewish Sabbath. Friday,
Friday, sundown, Saturday, sundown. And
this is this is how Yeah. This is how I
could tell people are not paying
attention. They're not truly digging.
This is not what Charlie preached. It's
not
>> right. So you you you'll see bits and
pieces. Um Mikey said it earlier. It is
truth mixed with error.
>> Whether it was intentional
or not, I don't know. But what I do know
is it was truth mixed with error. And we
have to be very cautious
>> to a Christian who's never ever picked
up the Bible. And then some I'm hearing
people calling this book the second
Bible.
>> Oh my dude, that's so blasting.
>> The second Bible. Wow. So to the so to
the Christian who never picked up the
Bible and this is the first book that
they pick up, it is dangerous.
>> This is a dangerous.
>> Um I got something right here. Actually,
>> see it says Charlie Kirk honored at the
church he attended. Charlie Kirk
attended Dream City Church in Phoenix
where he was known for his unashamed
faith and hosting rallies with President
Trump. He was known for attending Dream
City Church. It's not a Sabbathkeeping
church. It's a Sunday church. Charlie
Kirk was often at um Calvary Chapel. He
was at mass even. It wasn't just
evangelical churches. He was his he was
married to a baptized Catholic Jesuit
trained. Like I'm I'm not just saying
that. You look up the school that she
graduated from
>> and it'll tell you it's a Jesuit school.
It's not some conspiracy theory. It's
not a secret.
>> It's convenient that she's the one
remaining too.
>> Yeah.
>> So now we're getting her her swing on
it, her take on it. That's what's
remaining for us to receive because he's
gone. So it's very interesting.
>> Yeah. Let me see if this is I'm kind of
doing this on the fly. Let me see.
Charlie Kirk was an evangelical
Protestant, but he was a sort of fellow
traveler of Catholicism, making common
cause with Catholic thinkers and
activists, often expressing admiration
for the church, engaging positively with
Catholic ideas, and even sometimes seen
attending mass with his wife. That's on
catholic.com,
you know, and and there's going to be
people that are like, "Oh, well, anybody
can say anything about anybody." But
this was the day after he
>> There's a lot of conspiracies.
>> Yeah.
Um there's there's photos of him right
here. I mean, this is this isn't a
conspiracy theory. This is somebody just
saying a picture of Charlie Kirk
attending mass at St. Bernon Bernardet
Catholic Church in Scottdale, Arizona.
The picture was um I saw the original
picture of this. The picture was taken
by a guy's sister. It's not a conspiracy
theory. He was just
he just thought it was cool that he his
sister actually saw Charlie Kirk at her
church, a Catholic church, and it was
shared online. Like here's a picture my
sister took of Charlie Kirk. Isn't that
cool? And he's attending mass. So, you
know, it's not a conspiracy theory. It's
just reality.
Okay. So, if you if you can um move on
to the next slide, I want you guys to
look at this. So, there's actually a
chapter where he references Seven Day
Adventist.
>> And this is where a lot of the hype is
is going on. Oh, he he mentioned
Adventism. Oh, he's keeping the Sabbath.
>> And this is this is how subtle
the the the enemy is. And I'm not
calling Charlie Kirk the enemy. I'm just
saying he he may have been in a position
to where he could have come to the
truth, but he was also used by the enemy
unbeknowing to himself. Maybe, most
likely, I don't know. Okay. But it's a
possibility
>> that he was cut short at the perfect
time. So, this book and whatever else is
to come forth from it can be a catalyst
for the one world government, for the
national Sunday law, and so forth. So,
here's the specific chapter. This is
just a reference where he starts
speaking about Adventist and Adventist.
I'm seeing them getting so so excited
cuz they're mentioned in the book.
>> But pay close attention. I want you guys
to see this. It says, "According to the
official 7th Day Adventist Church
manual, the Sabbath is a symbol of our
redemption in Christ, a sign of
sanctification, a to a token of our
allegiance, and a foretaste of of our
eternal future in God's kingdom." The
Adventist Church teaches that Sabbath
observance is both a present blessing
and a prophetic marker pointing forward
to the rest and restoration promised at
Christ's return. This theological
view is deeply holistic encompassing
physical rest, mental peace, social
bonding. I could keep on going.
Basically, this he was talking about
event that took place that he
participated in. They invited him
>> to
>> where he spoke at. I don't know if you
could pull that fly up.
>> The wisdom pearl. There we go.
>> Yeah. So, this was the wisdom pearl and
look at the dates that it took place.
So, this was March 27th to March 29th.
You can see some SDA P I SDA uh pastors
here. Um I see Ben Carson. I see Pastor
Kelly. So he was invited to the platform
to speak and um I don't know if you can
move on again to the next slide and you
can see
>> wow that was at dream city church that's
where it says venue. Wow interesting.
>> Yes. So here um falcrum for those who
don't know they wrote about it and look
what they said about Charlie Kirk as he
was going to speak at this this
was before the death.
>> Yes this was before the death. Remember
the se the seventh day Sabbath panel a
special um discussion led by Charlie
Kirk a newly committed notice he's a
newly committed 7th day Sabbath observer
alongside distinguished panelists and so
forth. So you can see he he just he was
just starting to learn and they had him
preaching there and um if you can
continue
>> that was the beginning that was mid this
year right January February. like the
beginning of the year. That was
>> Yeah, the beginning of this year. Wow.
Wow. What are the chances, dude?
>> Look at that.
>> So, as [snorts] you continue continue
on, I want y'all to see look at the um
y'all might this this might look
familiar, but for those who don't know,
I'm going to tell y'all what this is. So
if you look at the bottom says Charlie
Kirk, founder and CEO of Turning Point
USA, speaks during the 2025 Young
Women's Leadership Summit and he holds
that he held from June 13th to 15th. So
this summit this summit took place after
the event where he spoke that we just
showed you
>> that took place in Phoenix, Arizona. And
in this specific event,
this was the event where his true belief
was shown. So regardless if he
participated in this um 7th day
Adventist event and he was speaking
about the Sabbath, it was the perfect
seed to lure Adventist in.
>> Yeah.
>> To lure them in, to be like, "Yay, he's
keeping the Sabbath." It was perfect
because now,
oh, he he's one of us, right? because he
preached the Sabbath. No, he preached
confusion.
>> I don't know if you could pull that um
that that clip up or we'll we'll show
it. No, matter of fact, can you pull
that
>> clip next?
>> No, it's not. But if you if you could
>> Okay, so now again, look at this event.
It's showing you this was the event
>> June 16th. Again,
>> that's what we were just looking at.
>> Yes. But can we hear what he said? Can
we hear what he said? Can you just
scroll forward? We'll come back to this.
>> Where is it at?
>> Is it right here?
>> Yes.
>> All right. Here it is.
>> We're very serious Sabbathke keepers. Uh
we This would be an exception because
we're here with all of you, but we'll do
it on Sunday. We actually take the
traditional Jewish Sabbath. If you don't
want to do that, I'm not here to debate
you on it. It's fine. If you want to do
it privately, I'll beat you. But that's
a whole separate issue. But uh it's
fine. It doesn't it actually doesn't
matter that much. What does matter is, I
think, that to our own detriment and to
our own failure, we as Christians have
decided to cast away resting on one of
the seven days.
>> One of the seven days.
>> Wow.
>> One
really matter.
>> Yeah.
>> That was his true belief.
>> That was his true beliefs. People would
get excited because they say, "Okay, for
real, this has all happened this year,
like you just said, like the beginning
of the year, newly Sabbathke keeper, and
he's sharing his beliefs and he's
saying, "We we do it on Saturday." But,
you know, since we're here with you,
we'll do it on Sunday. Already, he's
saying, you know, he he is saying that
the Sabbath is on Saturday, according to
the Bible, the seventh day. But he's
saying, "But since we're here with you,
we'll do it on Sunday. No big deal."
>> Right.
>> And then he's like,
>> "That's why we've been neutralized."
>> Yeah. And then it's like, you know, we
can debate it and I'll win. Haha. Make a
little joke. But then it's like, but it
really all seriousness, it doesn't
really matter the day.
>> Right. That's exactly
>> what matters is that we keep one of
them,
>> right? But we hold on we hold on to
those those talking points that say, you
know, I'll I'll beat you and these kinds
of things. We're like, "Oh, yeah. Yeah,
you know, that's that's strong. That's
powerful." And then right after that, he
says, "But it really doesn't matter." He
just completely discredits it
>> and negates it right after that. And
that's what we're left with. And we
don't even realize that.
>> Wow, dude.
>> Now, can God can God still use this as
an opportunity? Romans 8:28 says, "All
things work together for good, both good
and bad." So, yes, it can be an
opportunity.
>> Um, but then,
>> but the reason why I I think this video
is so important
>> because there are there were a lot of
Adventists who were jumping on the bad
bandwagon and sympathizing and they
weren't doing their deep research.
>> Oh, he he preached this. No, he didn't
preach the Sabbath. He preached
confusion.
>> I don't know if you could go back all
the way to the the the other slide so we
don't miss the
>> No, I got Well, it's one thing for him
to give his testimony like if say, "Hey,
you know, this is something that I'm
doing, but then to speak from authority,
which is he's constantly doing he's
speaking from authority."
>> Yeah.
>> And then we we are bringing him up to
speak from authority. So, it's a
completely different thing. And that's
you shouldn't be doing that with someone
who's new, who doesn't understand,
>> because then he's going to be pushing
confusion whether we want it, whether we
want to believe it or not. He's going to
push confusion on.
>> Yeah. Whether he's genuine or not, even
a genuine person, you should not be
putting them that far into a leadership
role when they've just been doing this
for months,
>> right?
>> Yeah. Say, "Hey, look, listen to his
testimony. He's he, you know, just
>> Yeah. put the disclaimer on there. But
we are letting them stand up there and
give like speak from authority. And by
doing that, you're going to have a lot
of people confused thinking like how
many people have said, "Is this the way
we're supposed to keep the Sabbath?" How
many times have you heard that people
are saying that from this book and from
this movement? No. Respectfully, no. So,
yeah, it's very it's dangerous.
>> Brad, you said something. You said uh
all things work together for good. Can
God use this? Yes. I want to clarify
because people, man, I've been doing
stuff like this type of thing for eight
years, even when I worked with Little
Light and all that stuff. And people
will look at like a Hollywood movie and
be like, you know, but God can God can
use anything.
>> My testimony is that God can use
anything. God did God can. That's my
testimony. But I'm still not going to
justify. I'm not going to go out and
create some some horrible piece of media
because, you know, God could use it. No,
you don't justify creating those things,
but because those things are being
created hopefully by the world and not
by the Christians,
>> God can God's just so amazing that he
can use things. I've I've um I remember
when I was new in my Christian walk, I
was a valet parker and I was just
>> I was really starting to get serious
about praying and stuff like that. and I
got in a car to move it and it was a
BeeGees song and it was I never even
heard the song before but it was it was
saying the things that my prayer was. It
was about uh being a light in the
darkness all this stuff and it it
touched me. I'm not justifying the
Beatles. I'm not justifying the Beeges.
I don't think that God was behind that
music or anything but in that moment it
was like I was touched by some words
that were in that song. And so, yes, God
can use anything, but it doesn't justify
creating it, you know. So, I don't know
where I was going with that.
>> A stepping stone, a stepping stone can
be used for good, to step towards good,
but it can also be used to step
backwards,
>> right? Yeah.
>> Stepping stones work. So, you got to be
very careful when you start arguing
stepping stone because you're going to
have a lot of people who were convicted
that take the same stepstone backwards.
>> Yep. And I know that's not what Brad was
saying, but I wanted to say that to
people because so many people will take
something and run with it.
>> And yes, this book, it was put out and
it was in my opinion put out for this
purpose to cause confusion, to push a
Sunday law, all that stuff. That's my
personal opinion. I do believe that.
>> That's my conviction. Yeah,
>> I agree. I also agree.
>> Yeah. But somebody might legitimately,
some new Christian might literally pick
it up because I've been hearing about
this book and they'd be like, "Wow, I
never Why do we keep Sunday? I never
even paid attention that it's really
supposed to be Saturday and and be
convicted and do it. It might actually
work that way, you know. But I I think
more people because this is what I what
I've seen is when the news was talking
about the Charlie Kirk effect,
everybody's going to church now. Guess
what? Nobody was going to Sabbath
churches. The church attendance that was
rising
>> back to church.
>> Yeah. of the churches that were rising
were uh you know the evangelical Sunday
churches and mass even you I did not see
the polls that said wow so many people
are now going to advent churches or uh
you know me messianic churches or
whatever I didn't hear
>> how about how about they're convicted of
sin and they're turning you know
>> uh when it comes to true revival true
and false revivals one of the points of
a true revival is commandments ments of
God.
>> Amen.
>> And
>> so with this specific situation,
um what is it doing to the commandments
but kind of leaving you with a skewed
understanding? So it's not really in
many cases you wouldn't consider it a
true revival. No.
>> Right. Yeah. It's a commandment, but you
can kind of bend it and keep it your own
way.
This is something that I I noticed after
after the event. you know, he was
supposed to be going on tour and all
this stuff. And I was noticing that
there's a very ecumenicalness
to this tour. And I've even heard
Charlie Kirk himself say that he's
ecumenical. We don't have that clip,
unfortunately, but I've I've heard it.
And look, you see Michael Nolles, he's a
Catholic. You got
>> Oh, yes.
>> Uh where is it? Um Glenn Beck, he's a
Mormon. You got Tucker Carlson. He I
don't know what he is, but I mean, I got
this picture of him wearing a red thread
in all these pictures. That's that's a
Cabala Jewish mysticism. This is what
all these celebrities, this is what
they're all about. Cabala. You got um
Paris Hilton, Madonna,
Lindsay Lohan. They're all wearing the
red thread. You see Angelina Jolie,
Britney Spears, Demi Lovado, Ashton
Kutcher,
Ariana Grande made a music video all
about this thing. And this is what
they're all into. This is what all the
Illuminati, Hollywood elitist, Michael
Jackson. So to see
uh what's his name here? I don't even
remember his name now. Um Tucker Tucker.
Tucker Carlson rocking this thing. I
don't think that's a coincidence. So,
what do you got? You got Mormons,
Catholics,
uh, Cabalists,
and I don't know if like Ben Shapiro is
here or what, but that would be, you
know, Jews who don't even believe in
Christ. I don't know if he's on there
though, so I'm not gonna jump to
conclusions.
>> Tucker Carlson is a
Anglican biscuit paleon. Oh,
well that this is all this is all just
ecumenicism, man.
>> So we looked at that. So what what you
got here?
>> Right. So this this this is important
because just to back up what we were
saying earlier, this is what he wrote
about leaving that event that took place
in Phoenix. What we just showed,
>> look what he says about the Sabbath. So
now you can see his understanding of the
Sabbath regardless if he's saying, "Oh
yeah, Adventists keep the Sabbath." He
said, "I left their conference, right?
Believing that if every Christian
community had the same commitment to the
Sabbath, there would be virtually zero
downsides.
>> Whether you believe you are bound to the
Sabbath or not, it is not the point."
>> Believe or not,
>> it's Look at this. It's a it's a
self-evident truth that if church and
Christian community turned off from from
the world for a day. He's not saying the
day. He's saying a day.
>> Really hard, isn't he?
>> Look, look at this guys. Come on. These
are his words. And you can't say that he
didn't have this viewpoint because we
just played the video which took place a
[clears throat] couple of months after
he left this event and he's speaking the
same lingo a day.
>> They would arise after 24 hours better.
Let's just skip to the bottom. It says
these adventitants observe a literal
Sabbath every Sabbath. So they are
saying we don't observe the Sabbath.
They say we observe a Sabbath. And look
at the play on words.
>> Yeah,
>> guys, go on.
>> Subtle, man.
>> You got to understand how the enemy
works.
[snorts]
>> Oh, dude.
>> Wow. That is
>> This is exactly how Satan speaks, man.
>> Again, continuing continuing on the
headline. [snorts] It says, "There are
many weekends a year where I simply
can't take a Sabbath." So, was he truly
keeping a Sabbath? If he's he's telling
you that he couldn't there were days
where he couldn't keep a true Sabbathke
keeper will keep the Sabbath
>> every Sabbath. You're not going to break
it no matter what. I was just I was just
>> placed in a position in my job recently
to where they were trying to force me to
work on the Sabbath. I said, "Listen,
you can fire me. You're I'm not breaking
the Sabbath." That's the mentality
>> of a true believer within the scriptures
>> of what the Bible says. That's your that
should be your mindset when it comes to
any point of the law of God. So it says
if this is your excuse then I finally
understand. In fact I resonate with it
about five weekends out of the year
sometimes more it becomes genuinely
difficult for me to take a Sabbath.
Events like America America Fest or
other major Turning Point USA gatherings
can demand my full presence and
attention. Occasionally, I'm asked to
speak at conferences, churches, or
public forums that fall squarely on the
weekends. And in those moments, I face
the same tension many of you do. How do
I honor God when life won't slow down?
>> Here's my answer. Here's the answer.
This is how he dealt with it.
>> I do everything in my power to plan
around it. I say no more often than I
say yes. I try to protect my Saturdays,
but when that's not possible, I get
creative and deliberate to work on
Saturday. I take Sunday as my Sabbath.
>> Wow.
>> If both days are booked and filled with
travel or obligations, I plan ahead to
block off the following weekend for
extended rest off, rest, phone off, no
emails, no [clears throat] output. I
double down. I lean into it. But what's
he say here? What does he say here?
>> Ah, [sighs]
>> you can do it your own way.
>> We got a lot of
we got a lot of believer uh leaders also
in the churches that are promoting this
book right now.
>> Yes.
>> And um the thing honestly the thing that
I see as I as I'm left with this book is
that
>> so the Sabbath is important but what is
it?
>> Where does it lead you? And apparently,
I guess if I'm reading this book, I can
take whatever on earth day I want to
take and I can just create my own day. I
can take Tuesday. I can take Wednesday
as my day. What's your day? My day is
going to be Thursday. You know what I'm
saying? Like that's such a power that
that's pretty much as I'm re Look at
this. This is the main message.
>> Sabbath is important. Pick your day.
Just like you version. Doesn't matter
what Bible version you choose. Pick a
version and it's going to be truth. But
that's not the case because some
versions are better than others. This is
like you version.
>> We know
Sunday law is coming. We know a one
world religion is coming. How are you
going to implement that? Christians, the
the majority of mainstream Christians
don't even think about Sabbath. Even if
they go to church every Sunday, they
don't miss a day.
>> They're still not keeping it. They're
going out to eat right afterwards.
They're going to watch the football
game. Some are going to work after
church. and then they come back to night
church or whatever, they're not keeping
the day. So, you have to have somebody
um to bring up the importance of the
day. But how do you do that? Well, you
have to go to the you have to go to the
Sabbath commandment. There's no other
there's nothing in the Bible that says
that Sunday is important. So, by
default, you have to go to the fourth
commandment. There's no other way. So
when that's why I was not falling for
this when this guy was coming out. I'm
like I'm not seeing a real firm stance
on when it is and what we should be
doing. All I see is that it's important
to keep a day. And that's exactly what
would have to happen in order for
everyone to get on board with the Sunday
law.
>> And right now this is like the
bestselling book.
>> What? [clears throat]
>> So he chooses Saturday. He just happens
to have chosen the right one. So it just
>> it it, you know, um
>> we're okay with it.
>> That's the day he chooses. Good for him.
>> That's the [clears throat] day he
chooses. But you choose what day you
want to choose. So Charlie said because
of that.
>> It's the day he chooses when it's
convenient for him. But when it's not,
his Sabbath is Sunday. Um, and I mean
like I this is just going back to what
um,
wow, my mind just went blank to what
Mikey just said, right?
>> I I I shared with you my testimony. I
kind of shared with it a little bit. He
he gives a powerful example because I I
had to deal with this firsthand. One of
the things when when when I was put um
you know to the test regarding my faith
in the Sabbath,
>> one of the things that my boss told me
was listen, you have other people in
this job. They go to church on Sunday.
We got Hebrew Israelites. We have Sunday
keepers. And he's like, you I I I
scratch your back. You scratch my back.
I need you to do me a favor. Compromise
your faith for me to work. And I'm
sitting here and he's comparing what I
believe in to Sunday keepers and to to
Hebrew Israelites who compromise in
their own religion. But I I realized
that as I as I opened my mouth and the
Holy Spirit spoke through me, I
realized, man, this was a witness. Cuz
when it's time to go, he's going to
remember this.
>> He's going to remember, man, he was
serious.
>> And that's how everybody has to be. You
can't we got to be a living witness.
>> You can't be wishy-washy as we're
reading here. You can't Oh, some days
I'm once you break that Sabbath one
time,
>> your witness is tarnished.
>> That's it.
>> Your witness is
>> because now now what'll happen next
time? It'll be like, well, you did it
last week.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, you can do it one week, but you
can't do it two.
>> Wow, dude.
>> That's right. Sin is a transgression of
the law, too. So, you know, I mean, if
it was the adultery, for example, just
just as once, you know, it's not that
big of a deal, right? But we look at the
ten commandments and each one of them is
important and the fourth just happens to
be as important as the rest. So, we
aren't really taking that particular
commandment seriously. And the way that
he says it, it's almost like, look, I
mean, in God's eyes, look, just go ahead
and go out with a woman just one night.
You're good. But yeah, you know,
>> if you can't see your wife one night, if
you're really
>> desiring,
>> right? If you have a desire and you
can't and your wife's not around, well,
why not this one? It's just one time,
you know, just this time,
>> man.
>> The commandments, man, they're serious.
We got to keep them.
>> Um, so here's again another example. I
think this was actually worse than the
last quote. All right. And it says
again, "There are many weekends a year
where I simply can't take a Sabbath."
This is the following page. It goes,
"Nowhere in this book am I calling you
to legalism.
>> The goal isn't a rigid formula. It's a
reordered life. I'm not trying to I'm
not trying to burden you with guilt. I'm
trying to provoke you to hunger. Just
because you can't rest every weekend
doesn't mean you abandon the pursuit
altogether. The goal is not he said now
remember what Erica Kirk said in the
forward.
>> Now this is out of his own words. The
goal is not perfection but pursue. Think
of the think of the Sabbath not as an
all all or nothing practice but as a
rhythm of renewal. You'll um you're
fearlessly um prioritized. He says,
"Even if you can only guard one week a
month
>> or one evening a week, build your life
around the sacred falls."
>> So keeping the Sabbath, you can
>> pick what you want you want.
>> Yeah. Just go ahead.
>> One week in a month. What is this? The
National Guard or something like what?
>> Dude,
this is mindblowing. I don't know. Is
anybody talking about this, dude? I see
everybody talking about this book right
now. Is anybody talking about this? I
hope
>> Well, maybe not in this way, but yeah,
everyone else is talking about this.
>> I hope this, you know, I I don't know if
this is true at all. I I I don't I
haven't fact check it at all, but I saw
a comment from somebody that said they
had a book and somebody else had a book
and there was different things in each
book. I don't know. I don't I don't want
to spread anything, but in case
somebody's watching and they can look
out for that, I don't know.
Well, we got the receipts. As Candace
says, [laughter] we got the receipts,
right? Um but um again, I just want you
to see that this is a reoccurring theme
throughout the whole entire book.
>> It um just the reading the highlighted
area, the Sabbath reclaims one day from
the machine and gives it back.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. I love that you're you're
>> catching this stuff because
>> it's not just the book where people will
say, "Well, that could have been
tampered with. There's a big
conspiracy." Just go back to his own
interviews
>> own words. Mhm.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Yeah. Because he says the exact
same thing. So even if he used that
argument, well, the editor could have
come in afterward or Tposa could have,
you know, tampered with it. Go to the
videos because he says the exact same
things. It's one common denominator.
>> Wow, man.
>> This is crazy.
>> I know.
>> Keep it rolling. Again, more consistent.
Now, again, imagine you're you're a
newbie and you read this book.
>> This is
>> and this is what you're seeing. As
someone who now observes a Saturday
Sabbath, I want to be clear. I don't
think the specific day Saturday or
Sunday is of primary importance. Now
look at the scripture.
>> Look at look at the scripture here.
>> You said that.
>> Yes.
>> Check the receipt page 194. He says a
Saturday Sabbath.
>> I want to be clear. I don't think the
specific day Saturday or Sunday is of
primary importance. Paul himself says
one person a look at the scripture the
misinterpretation of scripture and we
deal with this all the time we know what
the scripture is talking about
>> we know we know what it's talking about
>> why would he do that see well I know why
but I'm for the person who's like
what what you just said think about
you're you're a newbie and your pastor
told you to get this book hey you know
what there's a great book that just came
out go get this book.
>> Mhm.
>> Well, my pastor told me that Charlie
Kirk said you can do whatever. You know,
it's like one day, another day.
>> What I think is interesting, why why is
Sunday even in here? Why where did
Sunday come from? Because people will
say
>> um you know, the day doesn't matter. You
could you could keep Wednesday.
Wednesday could be your Sabbath. It it's
only an issue when you say you keep
Saturday. Have you realized that
>> you you can be talking about the Sabbath
to people and let's say the day doesn't
matter. I don't care if it's Wednesday
can be your Sabbath. And then you'll
say, um, I can't do that because it's
the Sabbath. They'll be like, oh, don't
be putting me under your bondage and
under your law and all that stuff. It's
like, whoa, I thought you just said the
day didn't matter. It's like the day
doesn't matter unless you're obedient to
God. That's the only That's the only
time.
>> Say it for Sunday.
>> Yeah. any day except the day that God
said.
>> That's that's the time that we live in.
>> That's scary, man.
>> So, this is that clip we saw.
>> Mhm. So, um yeah, go ahead. Um Mikey.
>> Well, yeah, we're just talking about how
this is exactly how Satan talks. You
know, it you can't just look at
something and say, "Well, I I agree with
a lot of stuff he says." Yeah, you're
going to if Satan came before you, he
would speak so crafty that you would be
like, "Yeah, that sounds good." Just
like these new age books, they have all
this, you know, Christ within and all
this stuff. Genesis 3:1 says, "Now the
serpent was more subtle than any beast
of the field which the Lord God had
made. And he said unto the woman, ya,
hath God said, Ye shall eat of every
fruit of the every tree of the garden."
So, Satan is speaking subtleties. He's
speaking truth. Didn't God say you could
eat of every tree? But he left the last
part off. 99% truth is not truth. And
that's how Satan speaks. That's why it
sounds so good.
>> Yeah. So, we we the scripture that he
used is important for those who don't
know how to um explain it. We we do it
here. So um he used Romans 14 I believe
it was verse 5 right and here we need to
understand that Paul is identifying the
topic from the very beginning of the
verse is so important that we read
context and not take one verse and
create a whole doctrine out of it and
unfortunately this is the majority of
the Christian world today that's in
deception this is what we do all right
and um so Romans 14:1 says him that is
weak in the faith receive ye but not dou
doubtful disputations. So the context of
that verse
>> regarding one esteemed this day and that
day is talking about doubtful
disputation. So what is doubtful
disputations, right?
>> Well, not a commandment of God written
by his own finger. That's not doubtful,
right?
>> You're talking about like genealogies
and washing of cups and all these
things, you know?
Wow. The
>> these are the things that can be dis um
uh again. Yeah. So, here's um the
literal Greek it translate judgments of
thoughts or discussions of doubts. Not
necessarily heated arguments, but
eternal um debates or scruples. These
are issues where Christians might differ
in practice such as dietary choices,
eating meat, drinking wine, or days of
observance, but where God core commands
aren't violated. That's exactly what
Mikey was just saying like it's it's not
talking about the ten commandments which
can't be altered. No. Right.
>> You know, so
>> yeah, it's anything but a doubtful
disputation. You know, often times as
Christians, we're trying to figure out
what what we can and can't do. doing
some of these like gray areas like well
the Bible doesn't say thou shalt not
play video games or whatever but it's
written in stone the Sabbath day the
seventh day somebody in here just said
the Sabbath is for the Jews. I've never
seen that scripture.
>> I've seen the Sabbath is for man.
>> I've seen um
keep my commandments. I've seen pray
that your flight not be in the winter or
on the Sabbath day. Jesus said this in
Matthew 24 about the in days to come. I
see that there's neither Jew nor Greek.
>> Yeah. There's neither Jew nor Greek.
We're all one in Christ Jesus. Where in
the world is there any any scripture
that says Jews do this and Gentiles do
this and we're, you know, God's a racist
and we we segregate on things that we do
on how we obey God.
referring to Mount Si and the giving of
the ten commandments and but there's so
many points uh that show that the
commandments were kept before that.
>> Yeah.
>> With the mana and the Sabbath and the
you name it. Uh Joseph with committing
adultery and all these things. It just
goes on.
>> Lucifer in heaven, you know, how could
Lucifer sin unless there was a law to
sin against?
>> Right. Pride. Pride found in his heart.
>> Yeah. He was putting himself before God.
We should put nothing before God.
But yeah, I like I like that you
mentioned that the Sabbath is the
Sabbath is actually mentioned before the
Ten Commandments u twice at least twice
where they're not to gather mana on the
Sabbath day. The the Ten Commandments
had not even been given yet. The the
physical stones had not been given yet.
>> It's it's great point.
>> It's and people, you know, that's that's
normally um the main argument that
people give. Oh, it was given on Sinai.
It was it wasn't
>> you know it wasn't given show me in the
Bible where
>> you know the Bible tells us to search
the scriptures
>> for they testify of Christ. So you need
to dig you you people when they're
reading the scriptures okay and I want
to encourage everybody there's levels
>> to the scriptures you you have to dig.
So for example you you sit here you tell
me oh where are the commandments in in
the Old Testament before Sinai? Well,
let me help some of you guys out. So,
Paul tells us in Romans that he would
not know, he would not know sin except
it was by the law.
>> So, the only way to know what sin is is
to have knowledge of the law, the ten
commandments.
No,
>> you go into the Old Testament and you
see God come to Cain and he tells Cain,
he he looks at Cain, he tells Cain, "Sin
lith at the door."
>> So wait, how does Cain know what sin is?
That mean he has knowledge of the law.
>> Or how about Joseph?
>> How about Joseph?
>> Yeah,
>> Joseph. How could I create this? And
this was before Sinai.
>> How could I create? How can I do this?
Yes.
>> So, they had knowledge of the law. This
a lot of this this stuff was oral. It
was passed down. You're talking about
beings before the flood who lived for
hundreds
>> and and thousand was it hundreds of
years.
>> years. Yeah.
>> Their their intellect surpass us now.
>> They We don't have the same We're
playing catchup. We don't have the same
intellect that they had. They were using
100% of their brains. We we we got a a
minuscule part. We This is why you got a
lot of people over here smoking and
doing all these drugs and trying to open
up their third eye. They're trying to
open up a portion of the brain that God
had blocked off.
>> Right. So
>> that's deep.
>> My my my thing is just
>> we forgot
>> study
>> Isaiah 66
uh starting with verse 22. This is a
prophetic thing about this is prophecy
about the new heavens and the new earth.
For as the new heavens and the new earth
which I will make shall remain before
me, sayaeth the Lord, so shall your seed
and your name remain. And it shall come
to pass that from one new moon to
another, and from one Sabbath to another
shall all flesh, not Jewish flesh, shall
all flesh come to worship before me,
sayeth the Lord. This is saying in the
new heavens and the new earth, all flesh
is going to worship before the Lord on
Sabbath.
If it if it was done away with, you
wouldn't have it reinstated. Like, this
is what bothers me. I've heard
Christians say basically, none of the
Bible is for us today. Everything I
everything I bring up, well, that was
for the Jews. And then I bring something
up in, you know, Revelation, well,
that's for the tribulation saints or
that's for the Jews. You know, it's it's
never for us. I'm like, we might as well
just burn the Bible. Like, I don't know
why we even have it because none of it's
for us. We should just be led by the
Holy Spirit, right? And not read God's
word. It's how he speaks through his
word,
>> right? They had a knowledge of these
things like you mentioned earlier. They
had a knowledge that knowledge has since
been forgotten. And so, that's why the
Sabbath day specifically starts with
remember because God knew that the
[clears throat] entire world would
forget. Man, I gota read.
>> I gotta read one more because
>> uh Jesus was so clear, man. Um
you guys are going to know this one.
Everybody knows this one. You just you
don't think about it because you hear
from a pastor or something like, "Oh,
that was for the Jews." You know, you
don't but you and then you forget these
clear scriptures that say Matthew 5:19.
This is written and read. Jesus himself.
Whosoever therefore shall break one of
the least.
>> Okay, if you're going to pick one
commandment that would be considered the
least these days, it's the fourth
because everyone agrees with all the
rest of them, right? The Sabbath is the
only one that's like an issue.
>> Whoever breaks one of the least
commandments and shall teach them. So
now you got people in the chat saying,
"No, that's for the Jews. They're
teaching it
>> shall be called least in the kingdom of
heaven." Now I want to clarify that
because people are like, "Well, at least
I'll still be in the kingdom. I'll just
be like a janitor or something." That's
not saying that. That's saying
>> no.
>> The kingdom of heaven right now is
looking down on you. Angels are looking
down on you saying you are the least. It
doesn't mean you're going to be there at
some lower level. It means that the
kingdom of heaven right now is looking
down on you calling you the least. And
then it says, "But whosoever shall teach
them like we are and the same shall be
called the great in the kingdom of
heaven." Look,
for anyone to say, "You guys are
legalists. You shouldn't be saying this
stuff." I'm going to what Jesus says. I
don't care what man says. I don't even
do it to be the greatest. I don't I
don't care what position I have in
heaven. I just want to teach the world
to follow, to believe God, to follow
God. If you love me, keep my
commandments. That's what Jesus said.
>> Yeah.
>> And this is this is getting good. And
now we're getting into Bible study.
>> Yeah. Romans 14:6. He that regardeth the
day regardeth it onto the Lord. And he
that regardeth not the day the the the
Lord he doeth not regarded. He that
eateth, that's the context, too. Um he
that eateth eateth to the Lord, and he
that eateth not. To the Lord he eateth
he eateth not. So again, context is very
important. This had to do with um uh
fasting or Yeah.
>> eating and not eating unto the Lord.
>> There there was man-made laws these
Pharisees tried to impose on everyone.
That's the whole reason that that Jesus
had an issue with these Pharisees and
stuff. Um oh, you're healing on the
Sabbath. Well, show me in the
commandment where it says he can't heal.
Oh, you're breaking off a piece of corn.
The Sabbath commandment doesn't say any
of that stuff. These were man-made
traditions that they were trying to
impose on other people. And so they had
these mandatory fast days. And he's
saying, "Look, whether you eat unto the
Lord or eat not unto the Lord, that's
that's up to you. It's not a it's not a
commandment."
>> Yeah, man.
>> That's good stuff, man.
>> Amen. So, this is just basically a
summary. So, summarizing what it is
saying and what it's not saying. It's
the Romans 14:5 is not talking about
choosing any day or whatever. The day
doesn't matter. It's talking about
voluntary fasting days, personal
conviction and not um in non-commanded
practices, unity, and charity amongst
believers, but is not talking about the
seventh day Sabbath, God's moral law, or
abolishing the ten commandments because
that would be contrary to other
scriptures. We're supposed to compare
scripture to scripture, and this clearly
would not make any sense. Yeah, we got
somebody in the comments saying, uh,
prove that Charlie wrote it. The, you
know, P TPUSA are top tier liars. We
already, we already showed where
this is Charlie Kirk's own words out of
his own mouth. He's on stage saying, you
know, I keep the Sabbath, but we're here
with you, so we're going to keep it on
Sunday, and I can debate you and I'll
win what day it is. But what really
matters, that's not really important.
What really matters is that we keep a
day because as Christians we've done a
disservice to not keeping a day. He He
was This is out of his own mouth. It
doesn't matter whether the book was
tampered with or not. If you can go back
to watch him.
>> Yeah. You watch him
>> show it again. Just show it again.
>> If y if y'all need the witness to see
that the book corresponds with what he
said, then here you go.
>> We're very serious Sabbathke keepers.
Uh, we, this would be an exception
because we're here with all of you, but
we'll do it on Sunday. We actually take
the traditional Jewish Sabbath. If you
don't want to do that, I'm not here to
debate you on it. It's fine. If you want
to do it privately, I'll beat you, but
that's a whole separate issue. But, uh,
it's fine. It doesn't It actually
doesn't matter that much. What does
matter is, I think, that to our own
detriment and to our own failure, we as
Christians have decided to cast away
resting on one of the seven days.
>> Man, that's so clear, dude. like one of
the seven. And there was a point I
wanted to make about that. Um,
so what I've noticed every time I hear
him talk about the Sabbath or Erica,
this is what it what they say. Yes. From
Friday sunset to Saturday sunset, I put
my phone in the drawer and all
distractions are away and I spend time
with family and God. It's like God's
like the afterthought. ask that
>> most of the time what I hear over and
over and over sometimes God isn't even
brought into the equation. She's saying
you know he's so bombarded that that's
when he finally puts his phone away in
the drawer and for 24 hours he doesn't
touch his phone. It's a Sabbath from his
phone. I don't even see like a whole lot
of
uh you know
>> corporate worship.
>> Yeah. I don't see any importance on
spending that time with God and keeping
it holy. It's just I put my phone away
basically. I take the day off.
>> But even even because I saw another
interview with Erica where she was
talking about what he actually did on
the Saturday. And again, it's not to
judge his character because I believe
that he was he was ignorant, you know,
in certain certain aspects of it. Um,
but I I there was an interview where she
was like he watched college football.
>> He watches college football. And and
when I saw that, I was like, you know,
so um again, like there's a lot of we
have to be cautious, man. Like
we have to search our sources. We have
to dig deep. The same way that I I I
looked at this book to find out if there
was any deceptions in here is the same
way I dig to look for the truth within
the scriptures. I believe the principle
for the scripture should be applied to
everything in life because you don't
want to be deceived.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah.
Um if Paul believed again Paul was the
one who wrote um some people esteem one
day whatever above another so forth. Um
if he believed that it didn't matter
about any day then and yah are
connecting Romans 14:5 to the Sabbath
then Paul would be contradicting his own
words because it was his manner
>> to keep that day. It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense.
>> No
>> that's right.
>> Um
>> is it did we already read this quote or
is this a different one?
>> No, this is this is another one. So this
again, this was in the forward, right?
And I thought this was important because
this this is what flashed into my head
as I read it. And I actually had this
conversation with Mikey. We were
talking. Remember Mikey? And I was I was
like I was doing back flips on the phone
because I was like, Mike, Mikey, you
know what you just said? That's
scripture. Mikey Mikey was didn't even
realize what came out his mouth. And um
so she writes here in the forward, I
knew Charlie so deeply in a way no one
else could. That is why I can say with
certainty these pages are not theory for
him. They are testimony.
>> And and so you think about testimony and
if you could go to the the the next
slide just so people could see if you
think about testimony right
>> look at Hebrews 9:1617.
This makes sense with what happened to
him. Why he was put to sleep,
>> right? For where a testament is, there
must also of a necessity be the death of
the test story. This was speaking about
Jesus. But Satan can remember Satan
takes scripture and flips it,
>> right?
>> Wow.
>> He flips it. For a testament is of
force. It says, "For a testament is of
force after men are dead." She said this
book right here is his testimony
>> and now it's a force because they he
>> Yep.
>> Now it's a force.
>> Well, that that's what I was saying to
you that made you think [clears throat]
of this verse. I never even heard this
verse. I've never I don't remember this,
but I was getting at that I I don't
think it's a coincidence that
this book was his last book. He quote
unquote died is there's this hero for
the Christian world who becomes in the
words of the media and everything a
martyr.
>> I've even heard Catholic priests say
that they're going to make him a a
saint.
and and the last thing that he put out
that that just happened to get finished
and published and everything like right
on time to be released a month after his
death or whatever, you know,
>> why why was the book not released while
he was alive?
>> Why was it right after he passed away?
>> And it's just it really doesn't sit
right. And then you have Erica that
comes in and she does take the baton.
That was a really fitting picture in the
beginning. She does take the baton and
she basically says, "Listen, I don't
care what anybody else says.
>> I am basically the authority now.
Everything that he believed, I am now
the mouthpiece for him. I'm the
mouthpiece for him. I'm TPUSA president.
>> I'm the mouthpiece. Anyone that wants to
talk, Kirk, talk to me and I will talk
as though I'm pretty much as though I'm
channeling him." It's creepy like that.
To me, as I see it, it sounds like she's
channeling him.
>> Um, whether you believe that he was a
double agent, past, whatever your belief
on that is is beside the point. The
point is that she seems to be channeling
all the energy that he harnessed
and now she's this authority and she's
pushing this. And uh I think the most
important point is that this book has
become essentially his legacy to the
world. And she's pushing that legacy
now. Like she's doing it. She's going to
all the talk shows and she's showing
this is what we're standing for. Pick a
Sabbath. Pick a Sabbath. We talked Uver.
Well, this is you Sabbath. So you pick a
Sabbath. We'll narrow it down to Sunday
later. But the point is right now, just
pick a Sabbath.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I mean, man, this is this is scary
stuff. Serious.
>> If you if if you look at it from a
biblical perspective, if you you think
about the situation from a biblical
perspective, a lot of people idolize
Charlie Cart. Some people he's he's like
Jesus to some people.
>> And so, let's just say this is the
Bible.
>> Yeah.
>> And she's she's a female.
>> And and in the Bible, a woman represents
a church. this church, this woman is
pushing out
his word of God
>> and the word the name Kirk means church.
>> That's why that's why to me this book to
me as I see it, I wouldn't recommend it
personally because unless there's all
kinds of disclaimers all over the place.
You're just going to lead people to be
confused about what is the Sabbath. He
didn't keep it like you mentioned
earlier. He watched sports and things
like He didn't know how to keep it
himself.
>> So, are we supposed to keep it that way?
Just a lot of confusion here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. What I actually said to you,
Brad, was I said
>> if he wasn't quote unquote dead, if that
event hadn't happened, this book
wouldn't have got 40% of the sales that
it has right now.
>> I guarantee that.
>> I
>> Oh, more than that. More than that. And
>> it's become like a number one seller.
That doesn't happen when you're just a,
you know, some speaker and you put out a
book. You're trying everything to get
people to buy that book, man.
>> And now they can't.
>> You couldn't try hard enough. You
couldn't try hard enough. It wouldn't
make it. But because of his passing, now
it's a national bestseller.
what you guys are saying again looking
it at it from a biblical perspective
Hebrews 9:1617 it says if the person is
not dead otherwise it is of no strength
at all while the testator li while he's
alive that book would be irrelevant
>> wow yeah
>> yep
>> you seem
crazy
>> that's powerful
>> so [snorts] Jesus said that think think
not that I come to destroy the law. So
in again these scriptures are being
taken and now like if you can go on to
the next slide they're being applied in
a different sense
>> and and if this is the second the their
version of the Bible and he's being
idolized in this way he's saying
according to his word within I have come
to destroy the law and prophets.
>> Yep. because
>> you can bend my whole
>> Yeah, he is confusion. Don't add don't
add don't take away. Um
>> for whoever shall keep the whole law yet
offend in one point
>> he is guilty.
>> Yeah. We're looking for you know for
anybody that thinks like oh we're not
under the law blah blah blah.
We're looking for prophetically the
lawless one to come upon the scenes. And
you literally have right now like one of
the most famous people of all time right
now of our time saying, "Yeah, uh, you
don't have to keep it
>> really. I mean, you can do it this way."
>> You're exactly right.
>> A lawless one.
>> This was the conclusion of the of one.
This is one of the conclusions.
>> Oh yeah.
>> In the chapter, the conclusion chapter
13. This is you saw how the book was
started with the forward through his
wife right where she talked about what
he did and now this is one of the
conclusions. Now imagine if America
begins
>> yes to honor the Sabbath with Sabbath
again not merely as a personal spiritual
practice but as a national cultural
rhythm. Picture Saturday or Sundays once
again becoming a time of collective
pause um when commerce slowed down.
That's when you see commerce slow down,
screen
>> dim, frenetic pace. What is that? That's
blue laws, man. It's coming. That's the
next thing. It's coming.
>> They're here, but they're going to be
pushed.
>> Yeah, it's coming.
>> From this moment though,
>> this is going to be the catalyst.
>> From this moment, we're going to see the
Sabbath preached from the mountaintops.
leaders and uh figureheads uh all around
the bat, whether they're conservative or
liberal, we're going to see the Sabbath
being just pushed. Now, from this moment
on, this is a revival. We're seeing a
revival. And um so we can kind of we
should kind of be looking for that and
gauging that there's going to be a
massive push now where we're going to
hear start hearing it from a lot of
people, presidents, leaders, ministers,
you name it.
Yep. I'm about to show you something
interesting if I can find it. Let's see.
International news.
[snorts] Uh,
>> have you seen the headlines? The
headlines.
>> I I took a screenshot of this.
>> I don't know why I can't find this. I
took a screenshot of this. I can't find
the actual article at this moment, but
see international the news. What is
this? How come I can't find that, man? I
searched it. Somebody told me about it
and I looked it up. Um,
>> can I read a couple headlines?
>> Yeah. Where you got?
>> We got uh we got Stop in the name of
God. Charlie Cook's Charlie Kirk's final
book honors transforming Sabbath.
And another one here's how the Trump
family profits from Charlie Kirk's new
book coverage from Forbes.
Uh we got WCC World Council Churches.
I mean this thing is literally going
worldwide. Rallies for a day. I mean
people are covering this thing. Pastors
are jumping on this thing.
>> You see what's on the screen, Jerry?
November 4th this year.
>> Smog crisis.
>> Wow. Let's look at it.
I mean,
>> yeah. So, wow.
So, for some people who are maybe not so
familiar, we are
um we're seeing a shift from God's
Sabbath, the [snorts] Saturday, Friday
evening to Saturday evening to the
Sunday.
And we're seeing uh a major a major
shift in Sabbath, but they're pushing
this idea of kind of like you Sabbath.
You pick your own Sabbath at first and
then they're going to transition that,
shift that to Sunday because that is the
venerable day of the sun. That is uh the
false Sabbath that is going to be
pushed. It's been being preached for a
very long time now.
This is uh today I found out.com. Not a
conspiracy theory website, not a
religious website. And it's talking
about what are blue laws. And right here
it says the first blue law, though not
called that at the time, was enacted in
colonial Virginia in 1610. And it
mandated church attendance at both
morning and afternoon services on
Sundays. A firsttime offender. Listen to
this. A first time offender. You don't
go to church the first time. What
happens? Lost his provision and
allowance for a whole week. You can't
buy or sell.
>> You know, so many people think that this
whole buy and sell means it's a
microchip. No. The you can't buy or sell
is the punishment. If you don't worship
according to the one world religion law,
you will be punished and you're going to
lose your allowance with a microchip or
a debit card or whatever. It's very easy
to cut that thing off. I don't know how
they did it back then. And there must
have been a an allowance like they're
saying those who committed a second
offense in addition to not being able to
buy or sell would be whipped. We know
that you're going to be persecuted. And
it said a third violation was supposedly
punished by death.
>> Though there is debate over whether
these accounts of early blue laws were
uh in some cases exaggerated or not.
Probably because not many people pushed
it to that far. They're like, I'll go to
church. get to that place.
>> Yeah. I don't want to, you know, I
already went a week without being able
to eat and I've been whipped. I don't
want to die. You know, I'll go to church
on Sunday.
>> That's what they're saying.
So, I think I think that's going to
happen again. History repeats itself.
>> Yeah. National coercion. That's what
we're looking at. We're looking at uh
laws restraining behavior.
And uh that's what this is. This is
going to become a uh liberty of
conscience. I mean it already is but
it's going to become a major liberty of
conscience issue where you cannot uh buy
you cannot sell uh unless you have the
mark of the beast and you you know are
fulfilling their version of God's
commandments.
And so that's why this is so serious.
This is this is nothing to be playing
around with.
>> Yeah, very soon. You know, they already
got rid of the penny. That might sound
minute to some people, but 2025 is a big
shift. I said a bunch of stuff at the
beginning. Aliens, AI, governance. We
got rid of the penny. They're getting
rid of physical currency. Right now,
it's the penny. Nobody cares. Next it'll
be uh all coins. I remember them saying
coin shortage and all this stuff. It's
never true. But
>> they're Yeah, they're pushing it to
like, look, it's just so convenient.
We're We shouldn't be cutting down trees
to make paper money. Nobody uses cash.
We're going to go to all digital.
They're pushing this digital ID stuff.
That's what this uh Genesis mission is
all about that that Trump just rolled
out days ago, uh November 24th. Genesis
mission. It's a it's a singularity
movement AI total governance where
all your it's it's like digital ID
everything you own is connected to one
identification. So now when you're
driving your smart car or you're in your
home with smart meters and phones that
are listen all the time and you get
caught saying the wrong thing. Well,
we're just going to deduct it out of
your bank. You don't get to go to court
and fight it or anything anymore. It's
just going to happen. And this is the
social credit score system thing that
China is already going through right
now. You will be a good citizen and
that'll be your currency because AI is
going to take over everybody's jobs.
Anybody that's watched this channel, we
talk about this stuff all the time.
Elon's been saying it. You know, if it
sounds extreme, look, you don't need to
hire graphic designers anymore. You just
ask AI to make some music. Uh Uber Eats,
all this type of stuff. checkout lines,
um narration, all this stuff.
>> What?
>> They they got drones dropping off uh
groceries. It's
>> It's crazy,
>> dude. All jobs, not all jobs, but a
majority of people's jobs are going to
be taken because of this. And Elon said
more than once that we're going to have
to convert to some kind of universal
credit system.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah. Basic income.
>> Push. Mhm.
>> And so what will that be? You don't have
to work. So what do you got to do to
earn money? You just got to be a good
citizen. Just be nice to your neighbor.
It sounds good.
>> Yeah.
>> But what if being nice to your neighbor
is you're not allowed to read the Bible
because that's a hate book. You're not
allowed to read that homosexuality is a
sin.
>> No, no, no. You're going to get
deducted. Actually, just go to the One
World Church. That's the easiest way to
to make enough money to make it through
the week because the universal church
will teach you how to be a good moral
citizen. It'll teach you how to be
tolerant, accepting.
>> Just go to the church, man.
>> Keep your mouth shut. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Just go to church once a week,
man. You'll be good to go.
>> And if you don't go,
>> you're dependent.
>> Yeah. If you don't go in the beginning,
it'll just be inconvenient. Like, man,
I'm really struggling here. But soon
it'll be like, oh, you didn't go to
church. Yeah. Uh, let's set let's catch
you doing that one more time. You're
gonna be thrown in jail. Get your head
cut off.
>> Oh, we are living in momentous um times,
that's for sure.
>> Yeah, dude. Let's see what we got next.
What you got going on here? [snorts]
Oh man.
>> Well, I I Yeah, I mean, this is
>> Hey, what? Uh the a lot of people have
been talking about this as of late, but
it just goes to show you that these two
doctrines are being pushed. This is
Revelation Revelation 13 where it talks
about
>> um you know fire coming from heaven and
so forth. We're going to see a false
revival and it's going to uh consist of
two things that's going to contribute to
it. You have spiritualism
>> and you're going to have Sunday Sunday
worship. And in
>> in one interview, these two things were
pushed
>> and we saw how she was speaking about
her husband who had passed away as if he
was still there. And
>> and um it says it here, I talk to him
when I am
>> um when I am getting ready in the
morning, when I'm getting ready to go to
bed, when I'm ju when I'm just going
about my day. So we know spiritualism
and um sun this Sunday um imort what is
it immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness these these things are going
to contribute to
>> the end of the world.
>> Wow dude this is freaky. And like I said
like
>> these people have the the biggest
platform now. I mean I I didn't even
know who these people were until this
happened. I I I'd heard of Turning Point
USA. I used to listen to Moody Radio a
lot. I'd hear him talk about Turning
Point USA. I never heard of Charlie
Kirk. I never definitely never heard of
Erica. And now these people you you
cannot not hear about him.
>> Yeah.
>> And And what are they pushing?
>> You better keep a day holy. And Charlie
still with us today. I can feel his
presence. I know he's here.
>> Oh, don't even go there.
>> And fake tears all the time. I mean,
>> I've never seen a tear, dude. Never seen
a tear. It's just
>> that's that's a that's a that's a hard
one. I when I look and I'm not trying to
be disrespectful or anyone especially
those who are very connected maybe
emotionally connected to her but for me
I see acting and it's difficult for me
to look through that
>> and um very and but uh I think that God
also brought out or at least he's
allowing us to discuss this right now
with the Sabbath and with Kirk Cameron's
situation.
>> Yeah.
>> With the eternally burning hell. We've
got these two issues now, which are the
issues that we're talking about right
now. Sunday sacredness and the
immortality of the soul. The two issues
that we're discussing right now that are
relevant, the two issues that are going
to combine like this and move forward uh
in an unstoppable way. These are now
being brought up before the entire
world, I would say, or at least in many
regards uh evangelical churches and
things like that. So we have these two
issues and we really need to understand
them and uh even though God is leading,
Satan has his twist on it. So we have to
be very careful not to fall for what
Satan is doing through Erica or anyone
else that is pushing this false Sabbath
narrative.
>> Yep. I mean
[sighs]
I don't remember what I was going to
say. I was thinking about something. You
you you made me think of something. it.
>> Yeah, dude. We're We are so close to
this thing coming, man.
>> I just can't believe
>> so close.
>> So, did you got a a slide in here?
>> Is this something that you got going on
your channel?
>> Oh, this is um I just want to give a if
you uh this is basically the woman
perspective on what's going on. We
they're continuing the conversations
actually tomorrow at 8:00 p.m. Um we
with Bible Impulse.
>> Yeah. Is it Tuesday?
>> No, today's Oh, yeah. Sorry. Sorry. I
forget the time, but Monday. Sorry. I
mean Monday at um 8:00 p.m. Um they're
going to be going over um the book also
extending the talk that we're kind of
doing now. And um it's it's just the the
female perspective. This is the RIB.
They're also a part of the RIB podcast.
We got a group of ladies on our channel.
We try to
>> we we try to implement. You don't see
too many women today, you know, sharing
the word, especially
>> most of this stuff is like it's it's
worldly if they're doing it. Like you
got stuff like the view, but this is
like the Christian version of the view.
So um these sisters Yes. So, Fridays at
um at 7:30 they do the RIB the RIB
podcast. Um and then Mondays and
Wednesdays they do the RI report where
they talk about current events. So
definitely look out for that on on Bible
Impulse.
>> Um is that the last slide on there?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Um
yeah, man. I want to let everybody know
where to find you guys. So if you want
to find Brad's stuff, Bible Impulse
right there on his hat. Jeremy, you got
Advent Age.
You can go to that on YouTube. Advent
Age
>> Advent Missions.
>> And I remember
>> what I was going to say was this whole
topic of the eternal torment and hell.
You know, we're not going to have
nobody's going to have
an excuse when Christ returns. We live
in the information age, dude, in in one
little small rectangle in our pocket. We
have the world's library. We can watch,
you know, if even if illiterate, even if
you cannot read, you can talk to your
phone and say, "Show me a video about
the Bible." Like, "Play the Bible for
me." There's every kind of way you can
listen to it. You can watch it. You can
read it. You can research.
We are living in the information age.
And you got bigname people right now. Uh
Kirk Cameron has 3.4 million followers
on Facebook. 3.4 million. And he's
coming to the truth that the
pre-tribulation rapture is not real. He
came to that truth 11 years ago. That
Israel and prophecy is not about a
nation, but it's about God's people, us.
There's neither Jew nor Greek. We're all
one in Christ Jesus. We are Israel. To
think that, you know, that Israel plays
this that literal Israel plays a big
role in prophecy is just unbiblical
>> and people call it replacement theology
and all this stuff, but we are Israel.
Um, and
>> that uh that hell's not eternal. You
know, he's come to this. He said, "I
believed hell was eternal because I
listened to people that I looked up to.
But when I started studying the Bible, I
see that Jesus said, "Fear him who can
destroy both body and soul and h and
hell." You know, um John 3:16, the wages
of sin or he whosoever receiveth him
shall have eternal life and not perish.
Those are your two choices. Eternal life
or perish. Wages of sin is death. You
know, the the the wicked will be cast
into the lake of fire, which is the
second death. They're going to be
neither neither root nor branch, ashes
on the souls of our feet, consumed away
into smoke, and be no more. The language
is clear. The only way you can be
confused on this topic is if some pastor
or some other Christian gives you one or
two verses out of context and says, "No,
the smoke of the torment rises forever
and ever." And then you turn a blind eye
to a hundred verses that tell you what
happens to the wicked. And so it's it's
our responsibility to dig in God's word
to to study it line upon line, precept
upon precept, here a little, there a
little, Old Testament, New Testament, by
the mouth of two or three witnesses. You
can't build entire doctrines out of one
verse, especially when it's out of
context. And that's what a lot of people
do with this stuff. Like, no, Paul said,
"Let let every man be uh convinced in
his own mind about the day or whatever."
When Jesus literally said, "Pray your
flight not be on the Sabbath day." in
the in the u tribulation to come, you
know.
So, this was great, dude. Uh great
research digging this stuff up. I have
not read the book. I'm not going to buy
the book, but you did the research that
all of us need to be doing.
>> Very good.
>> Yeah, man. Did you have any final words?
>> Yeah, some of those slides
Some of those slides were almost
unbelievable.
>> They are. I didn't know that. reading
the things that
>> like almost very strategic how the
wording was placed in each one of those
>> sections
a day and you know almost written in
such a way where you would really focus
on that a day
>> you know what I mean like really really
like wow okay so it doesn't really
matter so much what day and that one
slide that just blew me away that said I
want to be very clear with you that it's
not about what day it is.
>> As long as you're just willing to do
what you can to make it happen, [snorts]
whatever you need to do. I'm like, what?
>> I'm not telling you you have to be bound
to it.
>> Clearly.
>> Yes. So, he's he's actually doing the
exact opposite of anything that we want
to have happen with teaching anything
about the Sabbath if you really think of
it.
>> So, it's a very very big deal. And a lot
of us who are saying, "Well, go ahead
and read the book." I'm just going to
come out and say that I do not recommend
reading the book. [clears throat]
>> Um, especially if you're a new uh
Christian, uh, don't. But, uh, if if
you're seasoned, you want to look at it.
That's between you and God. But just
amazed by those quotes. So, thank you,
Esar quotes. Very, very powerful.
>> Yeah, man. I I would even go as far as
to to think maybe
Turning Point USA bought a bunch of
their own books to make it a bestseller.
That's that happened with Darwin's um
theory of evolution, you know, that
nobody was going to buy that. Nobody
believed that garbage, but he had some
rich person buy a bunch of the books and
then it became, you know, a bestseller
and it was in it got into schools and
everything. So there's all kinds of ways
to manufacture what
>> what the elite want, what Satan
ultimately wants to happen.
>> And I believe that's pushing towards a
one world religion.
>> Um
>> Go ahead.
No, I'll just say um
uh with the with the times that we're
living in, we have to be diligent and um
Satan's deceptions, they're obviously
they're subtle and as we get closer
towards the end, they're going to be
more deceptions.
>> Um he has he has tricks for every
denomination.
>> That's right.
>> For every um every race. He He He's been
here for 6,000 years studying human
nature.
>> Yeah. Our psych
>> studying our characters. Yes. He's he's
he's mad. And I I believe there's
there's nothing worse than someone who
doesn't have anything to lose because
according to the scriptures and he is a
student. Satan is a student of the
scriptures according to the scriptures.
Imagine reading a book and it tells you
how how your life is going to end.
>> Yeah. Yet you still believe this is this
is what sin does to you. The book is
telling Satan how he's going his life is
going to end. Yet he still believes that
he has a chance even even then. And then
and then now it's gotten to the point to
where listen, okay, it's over, right?
Let's say he has that mindset. It's
over. I'm taking everyone down with me.
>> Yep.
>> I'm taking everyone down with me. So,
the only way to make sure that we're in
good standard with Christ is that we
read this word, we study it, but most
important, we apply it to our lives. And
um we'll all be in the kingdom sooner or
later. I mean, this thing we're it's
right around the corner. And I'm I'm
about you guys, but I'm
>> I'm tired of this world, man. I want to
I want to go home. I'm tired of this
home. This hometown.
>> Yeah.
>> I want to go I want to go home.
I'm definitely sick of it, man.
>> This world has nothing to offer me,
dude. I've had it all and it's all
vanity. Vanity, man.
>> Um, I want to I want to give a little
shout out to y'all's
>> pages. I'm trying to find You said
Advent Age Mission. Oh,
>> Advent Missions with an S. Find it on
YouTube.
>> Check it out. We are
We don't have [snorts] 1,000 subscribers
yet, but we're getting close. So, push
it, guys.
>> So, here's Bible Impulse and got a lot
of good stuff under videos. Man, you
you're putting stuff out all the time,
dude. Brad's involved in a lot of stuff.
Kids ministry, women's ministries. Him
and his wife do this together. They got
live tab, the rib report, that's the
women's stuff. And
Jeremy has an actual building, a
brickandmortar
uh building where they do big events
often. You've been doing like
>> two and three a year
>> and uh camp meetings where people come
out for the whole weekend
>> and have awesome speakers that I look up
to and and really respect.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. We're Andy, my Andy, my
brother.
>> Yeah.
>> So, yeah, man. Definitely check out
their channels.
>> Yeah, man. This This is everything,
right? You guys didn't have any last
words or
>> you y'all could also uh visit uh
bibleimpulse.com. There's a lot of good
information on there. We just uh as a
ministry, we're working on a new
project. Um, we we we're starting now to
release music. We want to touch every
aspect of ministry. We we do we do we do
children uh we we work with children
every Sunday. Okay. Um me and my wife,
we have a marriage ministry. We have the
sisters that do the rib podcast. Guys, I
work a a a nine-to-five job.
>> Yeah.
>> And I come home and I slave to do this
ministry stuff and I believe God is
going to answer my prayer to where I can
go into full-time ministry. But I know
the sacrifice is eventually going to pay
off. Souls are so important, especially
with this little time that we got we got
left. So, as the information that God
has blessed me, has blessed um Mikey and
Jared and me to go out and share with
you is so important, you know. So, um
it's it's so
amazing that we could come together and
just talk about truth, man. Like this
this brings joy and and I know that
there's there's people out there that
they're watching and um they heard a
fruitful message today and many more to
come in the future. Amen. [snorts]
Well, you guys stick around and I'll uh
give you guys an official goodbye. I'm
going to sign off. If you guys were
blessed by this, please give it a thumbs
up. It really helps get this video out
into the algorithm. There are so many
people that need to see what we just
showed you guys. Like this this
discernment of seeing just a little
piece there and a little error there.
That's what deception is. A lot of truth
with a little bit of error. If you'd
like to support this ministry, you can
do so by going to candidruth.org. We got
Cash App, Vinmo, PayPal. We even have
Patreon. And if you like t-shirts and
hoodies and mugs and things like that,
we get about $5 for every sale on that.
And we are a 100% donor-based ministry.
We cannot do this without you guys. We
thank you so much for all your donations
that keep this thing going. And we've
been able to uh work towards year two.
We love you guys. We thank you guys. And
we will see you next time on Can of
Truth.